okay we have a another
strong player who who wants to play this
increment so
let's give him a chance so i think it's
a grand master by one is move so this
uh this is not supposed to be easy at
all
i'll play fast anyway
all right so let's castle and then we'll
think um
think of our plans
so i don't want to i don't want to go d5
here
as then my bishop on b7 will be stupid
so i'll just chew a little and uh wait
for him talked
okay once again rookie bishop of fate is
never a bad idea as well
i also feel like those who play this
random system they are
sort of expecting you to do something
and then when you just wait they
kind of get confused
so can we go e5
okay let's just do this
otherwise we'll never find out
so after b5 we have many moves so he has
to take first
correct now we probably take with the
knight if we are
really scared but why why not to take
with the pawn
yeah i guess we can take with a pawn
so now knight e4 is logical b5 is also
logical
yet a little bit risky
after b wow he goes rd1 which is uh
which is even better probably
we can actually play uh knight e4 just
to do knight d4 just troll him little
and once again i find my myself in a
state where
i just don't really care to be honest
so after ed i want to go e4 the as the
point was to block the d file
i mean i'm pretty sure he will go ed
anyway
i mean you need to be unbelievably
chickenish to go queen f1 or something
he takes this way okay and goes e4 so
this is logical so we can once again uh
use this motif to go 95
and bring the knight to c3
yeah so in terms of ideas we also need
to go
i mean we sort of want to trade the the
bishops by uh playing bishop d6
but then he probably goes e5
e5 let's say we go bishop takes bishop
takes knight f4
queen g4 wins this is sad
then
[Music]
we can obviously just go um
just go knights three but i want to do
something else for
whatever reason maybe i want to go queen
g5 actually
all right so let's say go queen g5 this
could be
some bad blunder but if it's not it kind
of makes sense
knight f3 queen h6
so he can take on d4 i'll just go knight
f4 probably
and i give up upon because i like
giving up pawns
there was no big reason to do this but
yeah for some reason
this is just the way i play
winning three now i think even the
ending should be
should be sort of okay for black okay
let's just trade whatever
and go g6
i don't think there is a single reason
for black to be worried here to be
honest
i would be a little worried as a with
white i would say but
i mean with precise play
it should be just drawn okay so bishop
h6
forcing the rook to go to some weird
square like f3 or g3
and so he chose f3
we can go rg8 for now
just to find out what's his next move
he goes knight b3 now we have many moves
we can just go f5 and get the pawn back
which is probably probably logical
enough not to
not to look for something better
i think he is actually getting into
i mean travel is probably a bit too
strong but i think black is just better
he goes rook g3 this is really strange
so what is the point i can just go king
g7 just in case
okay let's just wrote him he he probably
had some idea and now we just ignore it
no no what was the point but i mean i
don't even want to know to be honest
rook f1 wow
i mean enough is enough this should be
just should be just bad for white
um
yeah we have many moves we can just go
bishop f4
rook f3 and let's say g5
or we can go bishop f4 and then fe or we
go
fe immediately i mean i still feel like
trolling him a little
so what would be the trolling move here
um i don't know
okay let's go uh bishop foreign g5
this is funny enough probably
yeah so now we can just take a pawn
which we should probably do
okay at least we failed to win in a in a
fancy way
which is already which is already
a bit unpleasant so now we need to win
just somehow
for that reason we probably would
probably try to trade queens
and then we find ourselves in a
in a very good ending
we have two bishops as the king is
centralized
it should be quite bad for white
yeah let's improve the pawn structure
here then we go e3 at some point
yeah for instance now we go e3 and e2
and we promote
okay thanks for the game